frustration among ccsd staff forced to
stand in very long lines after school
for covid testing thank you for joining
us at 11 i'm brian loftis and i'm denise
valdez ccsd tells us those in line are
subject to mandatory testing because
they're either unvaccinated or haven't
shown proof of vaccination madison
kimbrough is live tonight with more on
what happened who was involved and the
response from the district
yeah today's line was so long that it
wrapped around the building at mohave
high school at one point they had to
stop testing due to the lack of testing
for kovid 19.
the line was wrapped around the
buildings i was
really really really like hot and tired
from being at work all day ccsd teachers
and staff upset tonight over the covet
testing method the school district has
enforced as you can see from this viewer
video ccsd employees were out in the
heat today waiting in line to get their
covet tests ccsd rules say if you're not
vaccinated you have to get weekly
testing and if you don't comply then you
don't work it's very inconvenient so i
kind of feel like i'm being punished
because i'm not being vaccinated
teachers heidi camarillo and tracy
blanks were all set to get their test
today but then showed up to an empty
parking lot i found out there was no
more tests so now what do i do now like
i got to come back again tomorrow until
they have more tests and that's 107
without no shade or water that's a bad
experience for us as teachers i had no
idea i mean there's no more tests here
i'm here to get my test i had to drop my
kids off do a lot of work to get here it
took me 20 minutes to get here now i got
to drive back home
and i was just curious why i didn't get
an email ccsd said in a statement it is
working to identify additional testing
locations and will communicate this to
all employees when available in the
meantime officials are asking for
patience and understanding as they
continue to work to ensure safety for
all currently there are eight different
testing locations
and now those four in the line are
either unvaccinated or they haven't
shown proof of their vaccination card
through the ccsd system you must do so
in order to not have to go through the
cova testing so until you do so you will
have to test covid every week until you
get that vaccination card reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now